Being around someone like you.
Like I used to be the guy who could,
I don't need to drink.
I'd go months and be like,
oh yeah,
I haven't had a drink.
Like you know what,
I'll have a drink and,
and you don't drink and you haven't drank since you were like in your twenties I
think I haven't drank since I retired.
Oh,
okay.
So last time I felt the effects of alcohol,
which I felt quite strongly.
Was that basically the day I retired.
Yeah,
you're in the day I retired,
which was October 1st,
2010 you know,
of course me and the boys,
we went out,
we had a bunch of drinks.
I woke up in the morning cause I still wake up early and I woke up in the
morning and I was like,
well yeah,
that's done because I've got other stuff I've got to do now.
And basically when I no longer had,
we'll call them friends to drink with.
Yeah.
Then I was like,
yeah,
well I'm done with that.
And I just ever since then,
just haven't really,
I've had,
and another thing is sometimes people think I'm like offended if they have
drinks or whatever.
And I'm hearing,
I'm not,
you know,
I remember actually I went,
I was on the first podcast I was on was Tim Ferriss.
Yup.
And we got done with the podcast and he,
you know,
we went out to grab some food because I was staying the night at his house and
we went out and we got some food,
we've got some mistake.
And he's like,
do you mind if I have a glass of wine with this?
And I was like,
Bro,
I don't care.
You know?
Yeah.
You know,
like a reformed alcoholic.
Yeah.
You just decided one day you're like,
my dad one day he was like,
Eh,
this gets in the way of work.
Yeah.
That's Kinda,
that's kind of my attitude doesn't really,
yeah.
I mean,
if I want to drink something that tastes good,
then I'll drink chocolate milk,
which I love the taste of Jocko white tea.
Right.
I mean,
that stuff makes me feel good and I just,
um,
yeah,
and people asked me about a lot and I need is something that I need to address
on the podcast because the other thing is just,
I might as well double into this a little bit right at this moment,
but when I was a kid,
I was into hardcore music I was into and,
and the type of music that I listened to was against drinking and against the,
it was punk that you talked about.
It is,
yeah.
We're talking straight edge.
We're talking minor threat.
Yeah.
Really?
Yes,
absolutely.
And so it was almost,
and I was,
again,
I was never really,
I'm very,
I'm not a real good follower.
So any time there's some kind of a movement going on,
I'm always like saying,
wait,
why is this moving going?
Why am I always questioned?
I don't just jump in.
I'm hard to get on board with something like that.
So it was around,
I wasn't like,
so there's a,
there's a thing with straight edge.
Okay.
So this,
this thing was called straight edge.
It started in,
I'd say you'd see the,
the epicenter of it was in Washington DC.
The first band really to coined the term was minor threat,
which is a punk band.
A heartburn if I've heard of them.
I assume they were partiers.
No,
not at all by the name.
No.
And so one of the things that,
one of the symbols of straight edge was uh,
you know when you go to a bar or when kids used to go to bars for a show for a,
for a music show,
if they were too young to drink once when the bouncer,
I looked at their ID card that they'd put a big x on their hands.
And so the straight edge symbol was they'd put the x's on their hands,
meaning look,
I don't drink.
And it's actually funny cause I took my,
two of my kids to see the white buffalo the other night in San Diego and it was
awesome.
And,
but when they came,
when they show their ideas,
they got the x's on their hands and I was like,
Oh yeah,
it always is.
So what the straight edge kids would do is they would draw big x's on their
hands,
meaning,
hey look,
I'm not drinking.
So there was the Adnan that of course morphed into like a gang.
And there was no,
by the time I was,
uh,
you know,
middle teenager,
there was hardcore gangs that would assault people that drank and would get
crazy vinyls guys and together with the Juggalos.
Yeah.
So it just,
so,
so when I was a kid I was okay and I wasn't like a full on,
I wasn't drawing.
I don't think,
I know I never like had x's on my story,
but I,
but I understood philosophically what was being said,
right.
Which was,
look,
I want to win,
right.
I'm hardcore,
I want to be stronger,
I want to be aware,
I want to be alert and drinking and doing drugs doesn't give me any of those
things.
So at that point,
that,
so sorry,
but even at that age,
you understood the fuel that goes into the machine affects the performance.
Yes.
See I didn't get that as a young man.
So here I am.
And,
and it was,
you know,
I was disciplined and you know,
I had a before the seals,
oh yeah.
I had a band,
a hardcore band.
The name of my hardcore band was rage of discipline.
That was the name of my hardcore band.
That was af.
That's what,
that's what Bronson's children.
Cause my first band when I was like 13,
was called Bronson's children.
But then as I got older I got more hardcore than it became a rage of discipline.
There was also about nine all,
it's broad since children Bronson,
she bronzes Charlesville he didn't drink,
I don't even know.
Oh,
[inaudible] name.
We do know Charles Bronson was a Badass when I was a kid.
I thought Charles Bronson was the man because he was the baddest man on the
planet.
He was,
you know,
uh,
a tail gunner in a,
you know,
bomber in World War II.
And he grew up in the mines when he was a kid,
when he was 10 years old or 11 years old,
he was working in the mines.
And until he was old enough that he used to have to wear a dress,
cause he didn't have parents that have money to buy him clothes.
He had to wear one of his sister's dresses down to the mind.
So then he went to World War II and then he became,
and you know,
he's just had great movies.
He always played this stoic character that was on emotional.
And so I was,
you know,
hey,
when I grew up going to be Charles Bronson of course.
So then we had a band,
it was called Bronson children.
Well,
as we got more hardcore,
eventually that name morphed into rage of discipline of which Elgin.
And James was the guitarist,
who's another buddy of mine that echo is met,
who will come on the podcast at some point and tell his crazy life story,
which I'm a big part of in the beginning until I joined the military.
When we get to hear the pre military Jocko.
Yeah.
So I'll be tuning into that one long story.
Then I joined the military.
Yeah.
So when I joined the military,
what do I want to be?
I want to be,
I want to be a seal.
I want to be a frog man.
I want to be the best frogman I can be.
I show up at a seal team.
Guess what frogman do frogman drink.
Okay,
cool.
I didn't know that.
Now that I know that,
give me a,
give me a shot of Jagermeister cause I'm ready to rock and roll.
And that was sort of how you proved yourself and that's what we did.
And I was immature and dumb and,
and despite everything I just said about like,
Hey,
I'm a little bit,
I'm hesitant to really follow,
well now I'm in the seal teams.
This is my dream job and this is what I want to do.
If you don't buy in,
you're not in.
Yeah.
And it's like it's not,
I don't even know if it's just like that's the way it is.
Yeah.
My first drink I was 17 right after I finished basic training,
I show up at the regimen and they're like,
all right,
what are you drinking?
And I'm like,
cause my family's full of alcoholics on both sides.
And it's nothing against them.
Like,
you know,
Grandpa was my other grandpa was and Grandpa's Grandpa was and you know,
one of my uncles,
okay,
they might hear this,
but like we all know what you do.
Okay.
Right.
So not a big deal,
but um,
and dad,
but dad was one of those guys,
he was like,
well,
that just doesn't affect me and me personally,
like you as a kid,
I'm like,
I don't really see the interest.
Like,
what am I going to throw up on myself and whatever,
whatever.
And I was one of those kids that say no to drugs,
actually worked on,
you know,
like,
uh,
now I'm older and I'm like,
man,
I should've been smoking weed since I was like 12 and shit.
But,
um,
I still don't,
but I did.
I just like,
you see the effects on people.
Like when I was a Bouncer,
I'm like,
yeah,
like the guy who smoked weed,
a really mellow,
and the guy that had coke and drank or like,
they were the ones who are the problem.
But,
um,
when I get to the regimen,
the first night of parade has done and they're like,
okay,
what are you drinking?
And I'm like,
well I'm 17.
They're like,
this is an army mess.
Like it's okay,
just,
we'll worry.
We're all going to keep an eye.
Like it's up to like,
I'm not trying to tell the world like,
Hey,
underage people drink,
but hey,
but it's an environment full of people that are there to look out for each
other.
Anyway,
so I had a couple of drinks and I'm like,
okay,
this is the way it is.
And same thing work Monday to Friday.
You work your ass off,
you,
you go hard as you can.
Like you go hard in the paint,
right?
Your,
your,
your tires are or are stripped at the end of the day.
Friday rolls around.
Okay.
We don't see it.
8:00 AM Monday morning boys.
And uh,
you know,
if you're going to drink,
don't drive.
But if you do drink driver,
that's what you got told when you were dismissed for the weekend.
Right?
Yeah.
And so basically have fun,
blow off the steam.
Don't hurt anybody and take care of each other is basically what you're told.
So the seal teams definitely is a culture.
It was even more when I first got in because now you're talking about the old
Vietnam guys and there wasn't a war going on and it was just,
hey,
what are you going to do if there's no war going on and you're,
you're a frog man,
what are you gonna do?
Well,
we drank and,
and I'm not,
I'm going to look down on,
I mean,
we had a great time.
It was fun,
you know,
it was,
it was fun.
It was what you know was what we did.
And I'm not even trying to say anything negative about it,
but that's what it was.
And unfortunately,
there's a lot of guys,
I shouldn't even say a lot.
There's a decent number of guys that don't do well with alcohol man.
And it ruins their lives.
It ruins or careers.
And that sucks.
It sucks to see.
I never really had any issues.
I drank when I drank.
It never interfered with my one year of your time in any way.
And you know,
that was it.
It wasn't a huge deal.
And I mean,
of course what I mean when I'm talking,
when I was 1920 2122,
I mean we drank a lot.
We drank all lots of weird how your body lets you at that age a lot.
Yeah.
And you got up the next morning,
we got up the next morning property like it was nothing we,
and that's what we did.
Um,
but then like I said,
and even now,
you know,
when I,
when I go out and hang out with some of my old buddies or actually it's more not
when I just went,
if I go and hang out with some of my old buddies,
we probably don't even,
you know,
maybe have a beer.
But when I go out,
let's see the young guys,
the young guys are getting after it.
I don't look down on them at all.
I think you know,
you're getting after it.
I found,
I've found when I hung out with my buddies that are still serving you,
not in the gig anymore,
you're not doing the job.
So you're a little out of shape.
Your,
your drills are a little rusty maybe,
or whatever.
I find when I'm around guys my age that are still operational,
I can't keep up with them drinking or because it's part of the training.
It's part of the culture.
I've fallen off.
And even like before I was in,
I didn't really drink.
And then when it got out,
I stopped drinking as much,
you know,
and it's not like,
again,
guys,
we're not Jocko and iron saying in the military were all functional alcoholics.
What we're saying is it's just what we do.
And you know,
and remember the job that we volunteer to do,
we,
we volunteered or run into gunfire,
uh,
for our countries and for fun,
like,
let's face it,
a lot of us think it's fun.
I thought it was the best time of my life,
but he's still got a blow off that steam.